blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman all right welcome to the show we
are going to be admittedly taking a tour
today
through some really uh depressing
and horrible realities about what's
going on
in the country in terms of the
fragmentation or
balkanization as we might call it of the
american right wing
there's going to be a lot of really
horrible and negative things we talk
about but i i think it's important
number one not to lose sight of the
bigger picture and number two
to also be a little bit less depressed
to start with what is actually some good
news not only about the pandemic which
i'll get to in a moment
but about the direction of the country
and the majority of the country
understanding that this change that took
place
between the last administration and the
current one it's not trivial
it's not irrelevant it's it's really
having an impact on people we have
new data from an nbc news poll
that shows that the percentage of
americans who say the country
is generally speaking going in the right
direction
has just about doubled since donald
trump left office
in january the day after
joe biden was inaugurated so january
21st
only 20 percent of the country believed
that the united states was quote headed
in the right direction which is often
the way this question is asked in
polling
but that share has improved to 40
among adults during the period april 17
to 20. and it it's it's actually
a crazy reality where we say hey
40 of the country just just more than a
third
forty percent of the country now thinks
we are going in the right direction
and this is a massive increase and we
should see that as a really good thing i
understand that that's a depressing
and incredibly low bar but understand
that first of all if you thought the
country was going in the right direction
under donald trump
your disconnect from the real world is
so significant that it's not that
reasonable to think
all of those people are going to have
some awakening once just
a normal person takes control of the
oval office
and the sadder reality is that that
perspective
that the right direction was the one
under donald trump remains the case for
tens of millions of americans and that's
not going to change anytime soon so
when we look at these numbers if you
showed these numbers to people from many
other countries
and you said listen we had arguably the
most destructive and unhinged president
in the modern political
era and at that time 20 percent of the
country thought we were going in the
right direction
we removed him uh his party lost the
house in 2018
his party lost the senate in 2020 as
well we have someone who now has built
one of the best vaccination distribution
programs
in the world in joe biden who passed
covet stimulus and is
on on the path to doing some other
things we're doing great now
oh and we still only have 40 percent of
the country believing that we are now
going in the right direction
other countries would look at that and
they would i don't know if they would
laugh or cry or feel pity or be scared
or whatever the case may be
but it certainly wouldn't make a lot of
sense so
there is no question that there's a long
way to go there's no quest
no question that the hyper partisanship
that we're experiencing
is going to create i mean listen the the
i don't think
in modern american political uh
space you would ever have
80 of the country say we are now going
in the right direction
for partisan reasons for tribal reasons
etc
let's take some solace because there's a
lot of really bad stuff we're going to
be going over today and i'm warning you
about that
uh in the fact that it has doubled and
then the continued good news as far as
the pandemic goes
uh the continued um uh improving jobs
numbers and stock market numbers and and
remaining
low inflation over the next six to eight
months hopefully we'll increase those
numbers even further now
from the standpoint of just
understanding the trumpist perspective
on this question were we going in the
right direction then are we going in the
right direction now
trump supporters seem unable to just
accept the reality that trump was
historically unpopular trump never hit
50
approval he left with 29 approval
and joe biden is relatively popular
given the polarized nature of the
country mid to high 50s approval for a
president in the modern political era
dating back to
you know the the george w bush era it's
significant in that it's not that common
trumpists
live by anecdote i don't know i went to
a trump rally and everybody there had a
trump flag
it and also when i look on twitter joe
biden doesn't get that many retweets on
twitter
their anecdotal experience plus watching
what newsmax and fox news tell them
tells them it can't possibly be true
that the country
is now more optimistic that biden has
higher approval than trump
trump losing in 2020 was proof of how
bad of a candidate he was he was gifted
a crisis
that for many other world leaders proper
handling of the pandemic easily escorted
them
to a just completely runaway reelection
uh trump had the incumbency advantage he
had voter suppression on his side and he
still managed to lose
people point to look at how many votes
trump was able to get
but they don't seem to realize the
number of people that were alienated by
trump and horrified by trump
led to record votes for joe biden as
well
and only half of that story seems to be
what they focus on this is a number 20
percent to 40
going in the right direction that if it
continues is a good sign
now it is time for joe biden
to get something else done now if you
look at
joe biden's first hundred day
accomplishments
they are significant they aren't all
exactly the accomplishments
that the progressive left would want
there are other things we would like for
him to have promised
and be working on and ideally have done
but
it can't be denied that it was an
extremely productive first hundred days
i believe it is now time to move ahead
without republicans because they simply
are not willing to participate
probably in the infrastructure bill and
senator bernie sanders
of vermont is now urging democrats push
through the infrastructure package
without any republican support just do
it bernie was interviewed
by axios this aired last night i believe
and he disagreed with the perspective
of some democratic strategists which is
that republicans must be part of the
deal that democrats
strike if democrats are going to pass
the sweeping infrastructure package
bernie said quote in general i don't
agree with that
the bottom line is the american people
want results and bernie said that
uh voters when it came to the 1.9
trillion dollar
stimulus nobody i mean listen you can
find some people right if you go to like
the villages in florida and we will have
video from that over the weekend you can
probably find some people who say
i was mad at the cash i got from biden
because no no republicans voted for it
you can find it a country of 331 million
but big picture
you don't have uh a wave of opposition
to the fact that people got money
in march or whenever it was passed uh
because no republicans supported that
and maybe even some republicans are
going to suffer the electoral
consequences of that
come 2022 and bernie is saying
essentially the same thing which is
what we've been saying what many have
been saying the infrastructure bill
is popular the infrastructure bill is
popular with almost all democrats
and a majority of independents and many
republicans
if republicans really want to dig their
heels in
or stick their head in the sand or
whatever metaphor or analogy you want to
use
and take the political risk of all
voting against something that americans
widely support
want and believe that we need and that
will be economically stimulative the
infrastructure plan
let republicans all vote against it
mitch mcconnell has already said
democrats will have zero votes on this
infrastructure package as written
uh we know there's not going to be zero
republican support
why negotiate into something that will
end up being
a garbage bill when even if you do that
you may get and
are likely to get zero republican votes
so it's really a simple question
is joe biden committed to doing
infrastructure in 2021 it's like a
really simple decision tree
if no then do there's then there's ten
options
negotiate and bad with bad faith
republicans
water the bill down postpone it till
2022 right i mean if the answer is no
we're not committed to getting it passed
this year
the the world is your oyster go do
whatever the hell you want
if the answer is yes we're committed to
passing it this year
uh then you just have to pass it without
republican support
as much as there is some risk to
democrats passing
another major bill with no republican
support i believe the risk is greater
for republicans when the bills are
popular
when the american people don't really
care whether if they think the things
should be done
most of the american people are not
doing this inside the beltway stuff of
oh i don't know i mean like if uh if
mitch mcconnell had voted for it then
i'd feel much better about accepting my
1400
that basically doesn't exist other than
anecdotally so i think the risk is
greater for the republicans
now there is a practical question it is
not totally clear
whether democratic senators joe manchin
and kirsten cinema
want the infrastructure bill passed as
written manchin has already played coy
with this idea of bipartisanship with
bad faith actors who have no interest in
what you're doing
cinema is also a question mark so
without a doubt bernie's plan only works
if you have
every democratic senator on board but
there is no question that it's time to
do it
and it must be done without republican
support because you're not going to get
republican support mitch mcconnell has
said it
if mitch mcconnell wants to obstruct let
him do it but get things done
i would rather if i were joe biden i
would rather
uh potentially suffer the consequences
for doing things without republicans
than suffer the consequences for not
getting a damn thing done
i think joe biden prefers the former as
well and
we're going to we're going to see very
soon if they decide to go ahead with
this
um monday memorial day by the way we are
going to do
our first one day membership special in
a very long time i think it was
february the last time we did this maybe
early march
we are going to have a one day
membership special it's going to be an
ungodly
immoral discount so if you've been
thinking about grabbing a membership
getting the extra bonus show every day
all of these things just get on my
newsletter
at davidpakman.com and then on monday
memorial day you will get an email
telling you how to sign up
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware
of for so long and other things got in
the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
made possible
by members viewers and listeners who
sign up at joinpacman.com we've had some
uh really good bonus shows lately we're
looking at uh
even giving some of them awards because
they've been so good
i encourage you to get instant access to
the bonus show sign up at joinpacman.com
coupon code available never mandatory
better21
are now really starting to get to what
is hopefully the
end game with the coronavirus pandemic
as many of you know a couple of weeks
ago the cdc as well as
joe biden in support of the cdc remember
joe biden doesn't come up with this
stuff
on his own he just goes by what the cdc
says announcing that
outside masking can be dramatically
reduced
for vaccinated people in almost every
situation other than very large crowds
gathering mass together outdoors
over the weekend dr anthony fauci now
signaled
what is really a major major step
in getting to the end of this thing dr
fauci said yesterday
that indeed he is open to starting to
reduce indoor
masking rules we know uh 999 out of a
thousand cases
prior to vaccination were being
transmitted indoors
uh and that we are getting to a level in
the vaccination campaign
now with 34 percent of the country fully
vaccinating
at vaccinated adding nearly one percent
to that every single day
um dr fauci saying that indeed we quote
do need to start being more liberal
in terms of rules for wearing masks
indoors
but just not quite yet not quite yet
we're down to about 43 000 cases a day
the lowest it's been for a very long
time but
at the same time not quite there yet
but very soon um dr fauci saying
it may be time to look at easing some
indoor masking guidelines and
that really will be a sign that we are
very close to the end of this thing
bearing in mind of course
that individuals who remain at higher
risk are going to likely want to take
more precautions bearing in mind that
in the fall or winter it may be time for
a booster vaccine
uh tweak tailored and calibrated towards
the main variants that
the the primary variants that have
emerged over the last several months
friday the cdc updated its guidance
about how the virus
spreads saying people could inhale
airborne virus
even from more than six feet away from
an infected individual this is something
that had been widely reported by
other agencies and researchers the cdc
now saying it plainly
so in particular when it comes to indoor
this is where the overwhelming majority
of the contagion
is happening that being said it's
dr fauci as well as the former head of
the fda
dr scott gottlieb all saying uh
we are very close to statistically being
able to ease off of these indoor masking
requirements quote
especially if you're in environment
where you know
you have a high level of vaccination and
that it would also
give public uh health officials more
credibility to reinstate
more guidelines if there is a surge in
the fall
that is problematic and doesn't uh isn't
well dealt with quickly enough
by the booster shots and i think that
that's an important point
both of them saying there's a degree of
fatigue
for lack of a better term with a lot of
these guidelines
and when the uh the data
justify easing those
if we need to put them back in in four
months six months eight months or
whenever
we hopefully will have more people
listen to us now i know that that
there are parts of the country where
nobody's going to listen and nobody's
been doing this stuff
to begin with but for those who have
been following cdc guidelines like me
hearing very concrete statements like
you really don't need to wear a mask
outside now that you're vaccinated david
unless you're together with a crowd of
people
uh that is great that is a great relief
and that also provides
an opportunity to have a period of time
if indeed things are going to get worse
uh where we can feel better about what's
going on i actually think that
from all the evidence we're seeing dr
eric topple recently tweeting
very good data about the vaccines well
handling the british variant the
brazilian
the south african the new york the
indian and the california variants
so if we can keep vaccinating hopefully
all of this will not
come to pass now there are people
who are not going to be coming out of
this they're they're just they're
remaining
home and masked um for the foreseeable
future even as the guidelines are going
to ease
and i think that that's fine uh some
people may do it
because of medical conditions others
because of a sort of pandemic induced
agoraphobia
this is going to be a real issue and
it's going to be an issue for some
period of time i think the point is
no one's going to be banned from taking
any precaution
they want to take but the numbers i mean
in some states you are seeing
a number of deaths which is the same as
what you would see during
uh during flu in other words there's
states where over the course of a year
five people a day die of flu during a
normal flu season and some of those
states are now seeing
five to seven coronavirus deaths per day
once it gets down to that point it
really
becomes more of an individual risk
assessment
than statewide or federal uh guidelines
or mandates
and uh that is going to be the direction
things are shifting and i think it's
perfectly fine
for people to make those risk
assessments for themselves
but when you start hearing dr fauci
saying we are soon going to be
liberalizing indoor mass guidelines when
you hear dr scott gottlieb say it
you know that you are getting to sort of
one of the last considerations
we just have to keep vaccinating today
we are going to be taking
a deep dive into false beliefs delusion
misunderstanding confusion and something
that maybe we could or should be calling
tribal psychosis and that's where i want
to start today
you may have heard that there are
attempts to do what some are calling
audit the election in the state of
arizona now you might say
audit the election which election was
there recently an election in arizona
that i haven't heard of no the answer is
i'm talking about
the november of 2020 election now more
than six months in the past
and there is a so-called audit of the
vote
taking place now i want to be 100 clear
with you this is going absolutely
nowhere
it's going it's going nowhere the
republican-controlled state senate in
arizona
um is undertaking a hand recount and
audit of the ballots and voting machines
in maricopa county which is the state's
largest county
biden won the county it was a republican
stronghold
biden won that county by 45 000 votes
the senate
in arizona has taken possession of over
2 million
ballots and 400 election machines
and has turned them over to be audited
by companies
that include one whose ceo is a
promoter of debunked election conspiracy
theories
understand who's doing this so-called
audit
it's not even clear that the auditors
are compliant with the law about
safeguarding ballots
but forget about all of that for now
here is an interview
with a guy named john braky who's an
official
helping to run this audit and he
explains that
auditors have a special light with which
they can check for bamboo
on the ballots now why would you be
looking for
bamboo are you looking to make flooring
or create bamboo rope
out of the ballots no they are looking
for bamboo fibers
because there's lots of bamboo in asia
i feel like an idiot even saying this
there's lots of bamboo in asia
and these auditors believe that if you
have ballots
with bam trace bamboo fibers on them
they could have been fraudulently
smuggled in from asia take a look at
this
the other day at the press conference
you were talking about bamboo what was
that about
well is that there's accusations that 40
000 ballots were flown in
to arizona into arizona and it was
stuffed into the box
okay and it came from the southeast part
of the world
asia okay and uh and what they're doing
is to find out if there's bamboo in the
paper
that camera right there that they take a
picture of the ballot
if you they can really look at depth
and find out is it a hand mark paper
ballot because that
it's a 5k camera you can see the folds
in the ballot because 92
of all the ballots here should have been
folded because they came in through an
envelope
okay and so they're doing all sorts of
testing to prove
if it was or wasn't and that's very
important because the only way you can
persuade people
on changing is having facts and we're on
a mission for facts
and i'm audit elections usa and what we
do is not about the right or left
audit is an acronym it stands for
americans united for democracy integrity
and transparency in elections
we've been around 17 years we work all
over the country for the last five years
i'm litigation of florida
i've sued in alabama i negotiated in
virginia i sued in ohio
and i've been in 18 states just working
elections and i all started because
of the bernie sanders election in 2016
with hillary clinton
i'm the guy who sued the whole state
it's genuinely difficult
to know what the most outrageous thing
in the video is now as usual the
conspiracy theory makes no sense
because number one bamboo on ballots
wouldn't mean anything
anyway like bamboo can grow in arizona
but also if you wanted to try to steal
the election
with so-called smuggled ballots of or
massive dumps of fake ballots
why would you fly them in from asia
where they've got to go through customs
much more expensive to ship
you would just make the fake ballots in
arizona it doesn't make any
there's no reason to go to asia for that
and then
you know bamboo fibers i'd be more
interested in look i think
barbecue sauce stains on the ballots
might be more meaningful than bamboo to
be perfectly frank with you
imagine being however old that guy is 65
70 i don't know and being so
totally unable to discern reality from
fantasy
in your life if you went to many
high schools middle schools even and you
presented this story to teenagers about
the bamboo fibers and all of this stuff
your average teenager is going to
question this and this is an adult
who appears to have completely fallen
for all of it is it a tribal psychosis
is it something else i don't know
super cameras to check for bamboo just
imagine what is going on here
it's like a uh it's like a turducken of
wrong it's a duck inside a chicken
inside a turkey
or like the the russian matryoshka dolls
there's just another layer no matter how
much you keep unpacking it
it's a joke and when the world sees guys
like this
searching for bamboo with a special
camera six months after the election
we are a laughingstock once again uh and
the fact that this is going on
makes me question how we've even
survived as a country
for hundreds of years and believe you me
these auditors were hired to find
fraud they will find something even if
it's just
we found some inconclusive
irregularities we need more ballots to
review
we need more study we need to keep
fighting this they've been hired to find
something
and whether they do or they don't it
will both become part of the conspiracy
as many of you know
the absence of evidence very often
becomes part of the conspiracy theory
for these people
this is not ending anytime soon it will
do nothing it's going nowhere
but i expect more interviews like this
in the future and in fact
we'll have more clips from this
interview
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
and you can find me on instagram
david.pakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you is high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today so we've already looked
at uh the current factions of the
republican party
the pro and the anti-trump republicans
the pro-trump republicans are now
split into sort of the q-wing which are
people that support
people like marjorie taylor green and
matt gates and then you've got the sort
of
pro-trump but anti-q wing
of the modern republican party these are
people that generally like trump
but they don't like all of these
problematic hangers on that have
surfaced republican senator lindsey
graham
seems to think that none of these
factions really matter
in so far as the republican party
absolutely
needs donald trump is dependent on
donald trump's involvement in their
party
and they simply cannot move forward as a
viable political party
without donald trump which is a very
strong statement to make
but there's a reason we call lindsey
graham flimsy lindsay and comparing his
latest statements over the weekend with
those in the past
will tell us a lot about that now the
first question
is whether lindsey graham is in some
sense correct in what he is now saying
whether or not he believes it right is
he simply saying this
because he's in trump's good graces and
trump's involvement in republican
politics is good for lindsay
there are all sorts of reasons he might
be saying this he may mean it he may not
but let's look at what lindsey graham
had to say over the weekend
just say to my republican colleagues can
we move forward uh
without president trump the answer is no
i've always liked liz cheney but she's
made a determination that the republican
party
can't can't grow with president trump
i've determined we can't grow without
him all of these people like hershel
walker and all the people you just named
are attracted to the trump republican
party economic populism
america first agenda if you don't get
that
as a republican you're making the
biggest mistake in the history of the
republican party
this is actually really interesting
because lindsay is not
wrong that people like hershel walker
and a ton of those that we saw being
interviewed or we're going to see
being interviewed at this event in
florida over the weekend
saying listen i saw it on tv trump won
all of this stuff
it is 100 true that a lot of these
people
never paid attention to american
politics before donald trump
it is true that it was trump's populist
rhetoric
and his america first agenda that
attracted them to donald trump
the practical issue though is what
effect that actually had
because trump's populist rhetoric never
materialized into policy
all the stuff trump ran on either didn't
happen
or it was perverted into some crony
handout
like ppp as an example trump's america
first agenda
ended up alienating much of the western
world
who were our long-term allies and case
in point
republican trumpism led to republicans
losing the house of representatives in
2018
losing the senate in 2020 losing the
white house in 2020
now the entire analysis is predicated on
lindsay is now being sincere
i don't know if he is because remember
that on the evening of january 6th in
the midst of the trump riots
lindsey graham seemed to say on the
floor of the senate
this is too much i'm out the direction
of trumpism
uh is what led people to riot on january
6th then he can't be a part of it
remember when lindsay said this
uh trump and i have we've had a hell of
a journey
i hate it then this way oh my god i hate
it
from my point of view he's been a
consequential president but today
first thing you'll see all i can say
is uh count me out enough is enough
i've tried to be helpful but when this
wisconsin supreme court ruled four to
three
that they didn't violate the supreme the
constitution
of wisconsin i agree with the three but
i accept the four
if al gore can accept 5'4 he's not
president
i can accept wisconsin four to three
pennsylvania it went to the second
circuit so much for all the judges being
in trump's pocket
they said no you're wrong i accept the
pennsylvania second circuit that trump's
lawsuit wasn't
wasn't right georgia they said the
secretary of state took the law in his
own hands he changed
the election laws unlawfully a federal
judge said no
i accept the federal judge even though i
don't agree with it
fraud they said there's 66 000 people in
georgia
under 18 voted how many people believe
that
i asked give me 10 and had one
they said 8 000 felons in prison in
arizona voted
give me 10. i hadn't gotten one
does that say there's there's problems
in every election
i don't buy this enough's enough we got
to end it
so the question of course is which
lindsey graham
is the sincere one and if he's posturing
and trying to get back
in trump's good graces now that it seems
trump does want to stay involved in
republican party politics
at least through 2022 maybe depending on
how that goes
into 2024 if lindsay is just saying what
he thinks
trump wants to hear is it even worth it
for the republican party to listen to
lindsey graham
trump may be great for lindsay so
lindsay can have the president on speed
dial
get rides on the presidential helicopter
and on air force one all of that stuff
but just because it's good and fun and
exciting for lindsey graham to be
friends with the president
doesn't mean it's actually good for the
republican party and
again if you want another example of why
they call this guy flimsy lindsay just
waving in the wind
going with whatever direction it's
blowing politically
this is the same lindsey graham early in
the 2016 primary
denouncing donald trump and accurately
so
remember this what is your reaction to
hearing what donald trump says
and disgusted well i'm going to talk to
the trump supporters for a minute
i don't know who you are and i don't
know why you like this guy
i think what you like about him he
appears to be strong when the rest of us
are weak
he's a very successful businessman he's
going to make everything great
he's going to take all the problems of
the world and put him in a box
and make your life better that's what
he's selling here's what you're buying
he's a race-baiting xenophobic religious
bigot
he doesn't represent my party he doesn't
represent the values
that the men and women who wear the
uniform are fighting for
so the point is i don't trust lindsey
graham
as far as i can throw him but it doesn't
matter
since i'm not trying to help the
republican party i don't need to figure
out whether
i need to be listening to lindsey graham
or not for me it's just a question of
will the republican party fall for this
the republican party on the other hand
does have to figure out their framework
and their structure heading into 2022
and that race starts in six months
understand that
there's not an unlimited amount of time
for the republican party to decide
which direction are we going to go and
are we going
the uh anti-trump side which is one side
are we going pro-trump anti-q
or are we going full-in q marjorie
taylor green matt gates these types of
people
it's down to about six months for them
to figure it out okay
i've not been covering the recent white
house press briefings very much
it's mostly very procedural and sort of
perfunctory announcements combined with
relatively benign and sometimes dumb
questions from the press corps and i
hate that that's how i'm breaking it
down but i think it reflects
the reality of recent press briefings
but this past
friday there was a really great example
of white house press secretary jen saki
using super basic simple
epistemology techniques that i've talked
about on the program
for a very long time to make a newsmax
reporter i guess they're calling her a
reporter attempting gotcha questions
look like the fool that she is and you
you really have to look at this clip
almost second by second because it's a
veritable treasure trove of
instructive critical thinking material i
won't even tell you anything about
what's in the clip
let's just start the clip see if you can
start identifying the logical fallacies
here
thanks jen i have questions on a couple
different topics first
um given the number of former obama
administration officials that are now in
this biden administration
and the president's relatively light
schedule there's a growing perception
that this
is really just the third term of
president obama
okay so already we have conclusions that
do not follow from premises
and we have false premises this is basic
basic critical thinking stuff the
premises are
and she actually says given that that's
how you know it's a premise
given that there are obama officials in
this administration
and given that joe biden is keeping a
very light
schedule now these are terrible premises
there are obama officials in this
administration
just like every administration has
officials from prior administrations
it's not unique
it doesn't tell us very much one way or
the other second
given joe biden's light schedule this is
part of the
biden senile and demented and can't do
anything
joe biden doesn't have a light schedule
he has a completely normal presidential
schedule
given that there's a pandemic still
going on trump did not
work for the final six to eight months
of his presidency he golfed
on nearly 20 of the days of his
presidency so
two false premises and the conclusion
by definition has to be false but also
it's false because uh there is
this is not an obama third term it did
what does that even mean
false false premises conclusion doesn't
follow
let's continue going back a few seconds
and then going further forward
and uh the president's relatively light
schedule there's a growing perception
that
this is really just the third term of
president obama what do you say to
people who say that
who were saying that who's saying that
you hear that a lot in the media
in the media different people okay so
jen
saki well done well done trump uh uh
uh people are saying says the trumpian
reporter she turns it into well who is
saying that
who exactly the reporter has nothing and
look at what happens next
like well there was lots of questions uh
about
when you had japanese prime minister
minister suga here
on the one and only so far in person
bilateral
head of state meeting it was vice
president kamala harris
who greeted the prime minister many
people found that odd
okay so now we get an example but still
many people found that odd
well hold on a second what people media
people politicians
random voters who are you talking about
she's already taking
independent one-on-one calls with key
allies like
prime minister morrison and justin
trudeau so
i just want to get your reaction to
people who question that
well it's hard to react when i don't
know what people you're talking about i
will say that the president
met with the prime minister as you know
and had a full meeting
a full press conference afterwards and
they even shared a meal
so and the president has had dozens of
conversations and calls with world
leaders and should be no surprise that
the vice president is also playing an
important role
engaging with and having discussions
with foreign leaders
there's really nothing there as you can
see
this was false premises a bogus
conclusion from those premises
and then an out of context single
example
when she just said well there's all of
these different examples
and she's able to come up only with one
and it's weak and it's barely connected
to what they're talking about
this stuff falls apart under basic
questioning
supply side economics implodes if you
ask
two or three basic questions debt
deficit
political football talking points they
fall apart
they have to be questioned and it really
doesn't take exotic methods to expose
this stuff and
a lot of times people will call in and
they'll say to me how do i
deal with at the thanksgiving table my
crazy trumpy
uncle saying this that or the other
thing and very often you know if you
don't want to start a huge fight
it's just about asking how they came to
know or believe the things that they
tell you
and it will very quickly fall apart
let's look at a little bit more now this
is the same reporter
apparently named emerald trying some
other gotchas the first one didn't work
on gensake
so she moved on to some other gotchas on
to dr fauci conspiracies and other
things take a look
that the nih and dr fauci
had provided funding to the wuhan lab of
virology
that's the 11th question when we talk
about the lab leak theory
and given that gain and function
research is dicey why would the us fund
that in china
i'm happy to send you to the nih about
more specifics of what program they
funded and more details of that now i do
have one more follow-up on that because
the president hasn't really weighed in
dr fauci
is one of the voices who discredit the
lab league theory but now there's more
officials
in the binding administration like the
the director of national intelligence
the cia director
and now also the nih director who say
that this cannot be ruled out
and there's cause for more investigation
into it who does the president agree
with dr fauci or the other officials
does he think this
it was a lab leak well the president has
said and i have said from here many
times that
there needs to be a credible independent
investigation
through the world health organization
and that one that relies on data relies
on participation from china
and other countries that may have
information that's certainly something
everybody has called for and we look
forward to that
happening spoken with president xi about
the origins of the coronavirus yet he
said
just a few weeks ago he hadn't yet i
think we have given a readout of his
call and also that the president
believes there should be an independent
investigation led by health experts um
and one where their data is provided
that's provided transparently to our
medical
uh and science experts here in the
united states and we look forward to
reviewing that
we're gonna have to go on i'm sorry
emerald i think you've had plenty of
time today
go ahead uh go ahead really embarrassing
i mean if these people were able to feel
shame she should be leaving with her
tail between her legs
and never showing her face in that
briefing room again i'm not even sure
how she's in the briefing room quite
frankly but that's another topic
altogether
i know that jen saki has young kids
she deals with these reporters almost
like dealing with little kids
you've gotten enough time i let you say
your thing i've humored you
let me go on to somebody else now okay
kiddo we can do more tomorrow
maybe if she's allowed back in well done
there
but it's not you know there's nothing
exotic or special that's happening it's
just well hold on
let's listen to what you're saying and
actually figure out if there's anything
behind it
this is a really good technique we've
talked about it before
and i'm sure that we will talk about it
again let's take a quick break make sure
you're following me on twitter
at d pacman and we'll be back right
after this
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him so we're continuing to
see a sort of fracturing or a
balkanization for lack of a better term
of the republican party
and um i mentioned this earlier and i
want to spend a little more time on it
now
you always used to sort of have three
wings of the republican party
you've got that pro-business low tax
wing that
may have been socially conservative but
they didn't really care too much
about the social issues um exemplified
by people
sort of like mitt romney although romney
as a mormon also seems to be a social
conservative but maybe less so than some
of the others but it's the pro-business
low-tax wing you then had the
libertarian right
so-called the the pro-liberty wing of
the republican party exemplified by
people
like rand paul and others of that ilk
and then you had the more
extreme evangelical religious right of
the party which was exemplified by folks
like i don't even know you know
louis gomer ted cruz people like that
where
they may have had uh conservative
economics beliefs but really their
worldview was informed
along the lines of social issues and by
religion
trumpism caused a sort of realignment
in which the simplified factions became
pro-trump republicans and anti-trump
republicans at least during the trump
era and
you had pro-trump republicans from all
three of those factions
and anti-trump republicans from all
three of those factions as well
sometimes it was less about anti-trump
but just kind of like trump skeptical or
trump agnostic in some sense we are now
seeing
the pro-trump side further
fracture into people who are pro-trump
but realize that the cartoons of the
party like matt gates marjorie taylor
green lauren bobert
these are bad for them and then you've
got the pro-trump people
doubling down and supporting the gates
and the marjorie taylor greens and these
types of people
this weekend there was an event that i
guess was part of the
america first tour at which
matt gates spoke and marjorie taylor
green spoke
and not only are the events themselves
absolutely insane
the interviews with the attendees are
even more outrageous
this took place at the villages in
florida
a real trumpian enclave so first off
without even getting into the substance
it's a crowded room with matt gates
signs
with queens we are the champions blaring
i can't imagine
queen as a band or any of the band
members would find any common cause
politically with these clowns i'm not
even playing the audio
because of copyright reasons okay so the
whole setup is crazy
then marjorie taylor green speaks and
she is still
going on about the so-called perfect
trump phone call
because the democrats impeached
president trump
over a perfect phone call by the way
these are parodies of themselves at this
point
a skit of what such an event would look
like
would be no different than the actual
event
matt gates then portrays the entire fbi
investigation
into his possible child sex trafficking
as nothing but a politically motivated
witch hunt which
ignores that the investigation started
when donald trump was president
and then he actually praises the
completely discredited project veritas
like
any whatever crazy thing you imagine
they could say
they said all of it at this event
we have a right to confront our accusers
in this country how about that there can
be no due process here
if the only process due to conservatives
is to see leaks embroidered on to lies
than just endlessly repeated by the
america last
media
[Applause]
[Music]
i hope you guys show the thousand people
outside that wanted to be
in here to hear this message but there
are sometimes exceptional journalists
who turn the cameras onto the liars
and in that vein let me say thank god
for project veritas
so there is no reason there is no common
sense there is none of it to be found
anywhere here and as you can probably
tell
uh uh it is not exactly
an event with deep political theory
presented or philosophical thought or
anything like it
for me the best part is the interviews
with the attendees
listen to this interview with a couple
outside the event
you guys both genuinely believe the
election was stolen yes
i mean that's you know if you believe
that that's true
that is that horrible yeah yeah i know
it is horrible
is it horrible that we would even be in
the situation to even
think that but it's false
no it is not why would they have all
those ballots hidden under tables
why did that man drive that truck all
the way across state lines
all of those ballots under the table
why did that man drive across state
lines
what what and the reporter tries telling
them this stuff has been debunked
it makes no difference take a look
the palace under table thing with
giuliani and georgia that's all been
proven to be false
it has not i watched it on tv listen she
that's
that's pretty watertight you know she
saw it all on tv
that's all there is to it and of course
where on tv
is a relevant question was it on newsmax
before newsmax
got the lawsuit threats and had to
apologize and take back a lot of what
they said
was it on fox news's lou dobbs show
before
he had to apologize and ultimately was
kicked off the air
for the constant propaganda debunked
propaganda that was being spread
we don't know where on tv she saw it but
we've got some pretty good guesses
you know i i i saw mr ed on tv
i believe horses can talk change my mind
it's right
there you can see it how does this all
get dealt with
at a systemic level that's the question
i've been asking for some time
and i don't know the answer i don't know
the answer but it is
really bad and i these people vote
it's their right i'm not suggesting we
take that right away we just have to
understand the reality that
many of these people vote some don't but
many do
this is a very interesting uh legal
story
in terms of the precedent that it could
set and we knew it was only a matter of
time until this was happening
and it's happening now the lawyer of one
of the trump rioters
who has been charged for his role in the
january sixth riots
which were of course inspired by donald
trump is using
so-called fox mania
and fox itis as a defense
for his client the 27 year old
uh is charged anthony antonio is his
name 27 year old anthony antonio
is charged with unlawful and violent
entry
of the capital police obstruction and
destruction of government property
according to an arrest warrant the
lawyer for anthony antonio whose name is
joseph hurley
claims that fox news is to blame
for the alleged actions of his client
his attorney said as reported by
huffpost
quote fox foxitis he became
hooked with what i call foxmania
antonio quote started believing
what was being fed to him says his
lawyer
and there is a very dangerous
in never-ending circle of liability here
to consider
because here you have a lawyer blaming
fox news
and fox news in the past has used
as a legal defense that at least their
opinion programming
is merely entertainment it's not news
none of it should be taken literally
and so is anyone to blame for this guy's
actions i know that as the party of
personal responsibility
you would think the right would be
saying well the individual is to blame
but is anyone actually going to be held
accountable and certainly
i mean listen what the lawyer is saying
isn't crazy
there is much reason to think that fox
news and newsmax and oan
they are partially to blame for inciting
and ginning these people up
for months with claims of election fraud
but there is also plenty of reason to
think that antonio himself
has to be responsible here we have in
the exhibits
in this particular case video footage
that shows
the defendant wearing a bulletproof vest
with a patch representing the three
percenters which is an extremist
anti-government group
he is seen shouting at officers in the
crowd
uh on video saying you want war we got
war
1776 all over again antonio was later
captured on video being handed
a riot shield which seemed to have been
stolen
law enforcement property he eventually
used that shield
to push his way to the front of the
crowd and then he was seen squirting
water on a police officer who was then
dragged into the crowd
throwing a bottle in the direction of
police officers it can all be fox news's
fault right although i do agree
that the role of media in getting people
fired up
by airing endless conspiracies even if
as they say
our guests were saying those things we
weren't saying those things
um there's no doubt that that that's an
aspect of this
but fox made me do it that's it
uh who didn't see this defense coming
though
um it was obviously
going to be fingers pointing at other
people even though he just got caught up
in the group he got kind of pushed in by
the mob
into the into the capitol building now
of course
they could also argue in court that
actually it was trump
as much as fox news is to blame trump is
to blame
call it you know instead of foxitis
trumporia or something like that
but that seems less likely to play as
well as maybe this could and i don't
know if this will work we're going to
have to follow the case
is there a treatment for trump urea
is there an antidote to foxitis or
foxmania
so we're going to follow the case we'll
see what impact it has
on the court because the precedent
setting power of this could be
significant and
i would be if this works at all
i expect to see many of the defense
lawyers for those charged in the january
six trump riots
uh to try to use exactly this defense
let me know if you think it will work
but also
you know not maybe not from a legal
standpoint
but obviously the rioters
deserve the lion's share of the
consequences for what they did
but how do you think blame should go
around
between merely the rioters themselves
who did the thing
donald trump and right wing media that
ginned this stuff up for months how
would you split it up
60 20 20 80 10 10
i don't know let me know what you think
and we'll have a follow-up about it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david
p and i hate that this is going on
but the anti-vaccine crowd the the covid
anti-vaccine crowd is getting
very belligerent and starting to adopt
more and more
violent rhetoric uh here is an
anti-vaccine guy who's been calling me
for a couple of weeks and he's getting
more and more fired up take a listen
hey david sarah from mass again i just
wanted to uh
ask you um you must have some really
good lawyers uh backing you up because
the stuff you're saying
and the advice you're given non-medical
about an experimental vaccine
remember i give no advice
that i come up with on this program i
state what medical uh
authorities and public health experts
say much like joe biden didn't decide
masks can come off outdoors joe biden
accepts
the expertise of the cdc so
there's been no original vaccine claims
made on this program i think it's
important
to to point out and a lot of people
don't seem to understand that i'm not
coming up with this stuff on my own
i mean you can get in some serious
trouble here if someone blames you or
something there's a lot of crazy people
out there
obviously i couldn't but i understand
the thinly veiled threat thank you
they're going to listen to your stupid
advice and the things you're saying
about getting kids
vaccined with a non-fda approved
experimental vaccine
what are you crazy right so this
is what we are up against if we are
going to lose the fight against the
pandemic
we have the tools if we were vaccinating
4 million a day right now
instead of two million a day which now
is limited
only by lack of interest the u.s you
know there's countries desperate for
supply
we have the supply we have we have a
lack of enough interest so vaccinations
have been declining
uh we could be far closer to ending this
thing
if it weren't for the point of view of
people like this guy
so uh that's extraordinarily dangerous
that the the rhetoric is getting more
violent
and uh i don't know what the outcome is
going to be but that is some
really scary stuff we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about the florida
de-platforming
law and its constitutionality very
interesting issue that relates to free
speech it relates to digital freedom and
so much more
we are also going to talk about
increasingly those
who is going to suffer in the future
from
the lack of attention to the climate
crisis today well it's those who are now
children
and children are increasingly taking
governments to court over climate
and they're starting to win they are
starting to win and we will talk about
that and lastly
is it time for the fda to ban all
menthol cigarettes some of you would say
all cigarettes should be banned but we
are specifically going to talk about
what's going on with menthol cigarettes
on the bonus show today
i had no idea that this was a
source of such controversy controversy
controversy and concern among the
medical community
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
memorial day okay very special day
we will be off there will be no show on
memorial day
it'll be a perfect holiday but we will
we will also be doing a
single day membership special one day
huge
ungodly discount haven't done this for
months and months if you would like to
be notified
of that membership special on may 31st
it's as simple as going to my website
and signing up for my newsletter that is
it my friends that is it
i will see you on the bonus show
momentarily
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman